well congratulations elon on your baby
news so who had the best reaction
to the news in your family oh my god
i'm truly already just thinking about
telling you about this but my brother
my brother's like um i don't know i mean
he's
he's sensitive but not always so
emotional
but when we told him oh when we told him
he he was like wait what oh my god and
just
burst into tears and my husband and i
just
uh made an elliott sandwich we just took
him in our arms it was
i'll never i'll never forget that
reaction what a beautiful reaction oh my
gosh do you
do you remember um howie whenever your
wife told you she was pregnant i
remember
the the not the reaction when my
daughter with my daughter who you met
has
two kids but when she told us she was
pregnant i was really excited but the
most exciting moment is when we
found out and this is just two months
ago who the father is
[Laughter]
oh my god want more fun stuff i thought
so
check out these videos floating around
my head this one is really cool
i'm just saying no pressure